I have a really interesting clip for you
from MSNBC where a conservative mother
and daughter and then some third guy I'm
not sure the relationship of the third
guy you'll see standing in the
background to the mother and daughter
are interviewed in Iowa these are Iowa
presumably Iowa voters in 2020 and
they're interviewed by MSNBC and first
the mother explains that she simply
can't bring herself to vote for Donald
Trump in 2020 take a look you were so
politically and why you went with Camila
Harrison what do you want well I'm a
lifelong conservative tonight I actually
campaigned door to door for chuck
Grassley his first year as a Senate
campaign Senate candidate but I cannot
vote forgot I just he is but he is not a
conservative but I don't think he's a
good man and when you watch a cabinet
member of the cabinet member fall away
from him I just can't vote for and so
I'm looking at the Democrats and I need
a Democrat that is
reasonable on our orders that is about
people
I'm an educator we've got to do
something about education and so that's
the person that I'm looking for and it's
really hard because they're all these
stem schools I really don't know what
they believe so you ended up voting
writing in John McCain in 2016 oh who
did you vote for quite frankly from the
way that this woman talks I don't think
there's any place for her in the
Republican Party other than maybe if
she's anti-abortion maybe that's really
important to her she doesn't sound like
no 2019 Republican I ever heard but then
it gets more interesting they go to the
guy in the back and he says he was
voting against Hillary in 2016 not for
Trump he almost seems embarrassed to
admit that he voted for Donald Trump
but then he repeats a totally incorrect
talking point that is spreading and that
we really need to stop like ASAP so take
a listen to this who did you vote for in
the general election this time around
could you see yourself voting for a
Democrat right now it's hard to say at
this point in the campaign that buddy's
running to the extremes on either side
they're all running to the extremes he
says no that's not true that this is
this is just a fundamental
misunderstanding either out of ignorance
or out of malice or something else Trump
is doing the same thing he's been been
doing which is to be an extremist in
policy and to be an extremist in
rhetoric that's no different Trump is
Trump and he's doing the same thing he
did as a candidate early in his
presidency and now Democrats are half
centrist sort of running to the center
left and half running on the normal
things that every other rich country has
no one on the Left is running two
extremes Biden Harris and Budaj are
running basically
unmake no substantive changes to the
status quo the rich people don't need to
worry as Biden said behind closed doors
everything's going to be okay that is
not extreme then you have from the
frontrunners who are more on the Left
Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth Warren who
are running on health care for all
dealing with income inequality a little
bit more than we've been dealing with it
dealing with corporate power to some
degree the basics that other Nordic
countries social democracies and rich
countries have already figured out so
this is a false narrative and the both
sides ISM that needs to be stopped
includes this story well listen
everybody's running to extreme so I
don't know who I'm going to support no
the left primary the Democratic primary
better said right now is a combination
of centrist Democrats that will be very
similar to centrist Republicans and a
couple of people that are running on
completely uncontroversial social
democratic policy that most other
countries at our level of development
and income have already figured out
right wingers are creating for
themselves this narrative that it's all
so extreme it's just not it's not
extreme on the Democratic side then they
go from this dude to the daughter take a
listen to what she had to say and I want
to bring you in real fast this is gonna
be your seventeen but you're gonna be
able to vote in November of 2020 you
you can see yourself conservative too
and your family but how do you see
yourself I can't vote for Donald Trump
and if there was a better conservative I
would probably vote for them but he says
so many things that are just absolutely
disgusting foreign policy is not
presidential enough so I really want a
Democratic candidate that I can get
behind and support like my mom said
isn't completely crazy on immigration
and really will make things like schools
safer so that I can have a place here in
my future and just make the country
better in general is there a candidate
that catches your mind call it Harris
right now like my mom if any of them
changed their policies so far I know
that a lot of my friends like Warren and
Sanders but they're little so again
Warren and Sanders are too far left
they're not they're totally standard
Social Democrats in any Nordic country
in most European countries and also I
find it a little bit odd that
immigration is so big an issue for
people in Iowa right I mean once again
it's talking point politics immigration
is what Trump talks about a ton we're
gonna have a report later on about the
number of lies that Donald Trump has
been telling and a plurality of those
lies are about immigration it's big in
the media narrative so Iowans who are
disgusted by Trump are talking about
immigration what about the tariffs that
are destroying Iowa farmers it seems
like a much more relevant and present
and nearby issue for Iowans than
immigration to of these three people
that were interviewed are somewhat more
thoughtful than your average trumpets
but they're still very skewed in their
views but my takeaway is this is still
good right these are good examples and
good anecdotes of some Republicans that
are saying you know I can't bring myself
to vote for Donald Trump but there's no
strategy for Democrats around people
like this what I mean by that is there
are people that are going to bail on
Trump because of Trump's actions to the
extent that we continue to report on
what Donald Trump is doing some of these
folks are going to vote for someone
other
Donald Trump we can't really waste time
trying to convince convince them or
convert them though as I've said before
it's not a strategy to debate Trump
esteem to change to change their mind
some of them will like these folks but
what our strategy needs to be is get out
the vote find people already on our side
who wouldn't otherwise vote half the
country doesn't vote combine them with
these sprinkling of trumpets like these
two or three who are bailing on Donald
Trump and maybe that'll help the
eventual Democratic nominee pick up a
state or two in the Midwest or a state
that Donald Trump won in 2016 and the
depressing realization and the guy there
said it lots of people are just voting
against Democrats that's really hard to
work with it's very hard to convert that
into support for the Democratic nominee
no matter what arguments you make so we
need to turnout our base there are
millions and millions of people who
already agree with us they just don't
vote they either don't care enough to
vote or they are too busy to vote or
they don't understand the importance of
voting and that's who we need to be
reaching out to